you're a war
crimes in is that
true oh my
God Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be AAR for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends you cannot make this up I've
said this before guys if they gave me a
billion pound budget and said make
Zionist look bad as possible I could
have possibly never be able to
orchestrate something like what the
sists are doing for free absolutely free
bro it's as if Allah is humiliating them
with their own hands on their own
tongues listen to this comedian on stage
happens to be interviewing so and I'm
watching this and I'm thinking no way
what he was about to say at the end like
you cannot make this up just watch for
yourself as he's talking about this guy
who's a investigator of war crimes guess
where he was was from all the irony and
the comedian face oh my gosh I mean he
just absolutely owned them let's watch
for ourselves this was so satisfying
you're an
investigator what kind like for the
police like war crimes investigation
you're a war
crimes in is that true is that true oh
my God jeez we really went up a notch
didn't we until then it was just all fun
like oh first date in the front row
you're like I'm here to investigate war
crimes
what are you working on at the moment
what's your Ukraine Ukraine you're
working on investigating war crimes in
Ukraine me man I thought when you
said infrastructure it was like going to
kill the energy but
you you came to win I like it and
are you are you from the UK no no where
you from from Israel you're from is
great oh my
God Jesus Christ
of all the places you could have said
you're an you're a war crimes
investigator from Israel looking at
Ukraine I think the call may be coming
from inside the
house oh my gosh guys you cannot make
this up W as if Allah is humiliating
them with their own mouth you go on
stage I would not even speak bro I would
not even mention if I was a Zionist
Israeli on that stage and this guy was
into me I would not mention my I would
never say I'm a walk I'm just like yeah
I'm just um yeah I just sell chips I
sell potato chips yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm a
cab driver I'm I would never can you
imagine so B I'm I'm a a war crime
investigator okay what you working on
now Ukraine okay where you from I would
never in the million years say Israel
say fa here no he's like yeah I'm from
Israel I mean you can't make this up I
just want to thank the Zionist we could
have not done it without you guys you
guys are flipping amazing with this when
it comes to this you guys are flipping
phenomenal of exposing your bloody
selves brilliant Round of Applause
you're from Israel and you are looking
at war crimes in Ukraine Bravo you
absolute flipping what a flipping
oh you can't make this up you cannot
make this up guys that's all I want to
share with you guys to brighten up your
day aldah these guys are moronic
absolute idiotic fools man you cannot
make this up there's a outright genocide
apart going the whole world has woken up
to your reality carry on exposing
yourself from comedies comedians on
stage to news anchors to you name it
carry an Expos it Allah subhana tal is
exposing you guys Al alhamdulillah
that's all I want to say brother and
sisters till next
time this was so damn STIs please share
this around the world please goodbye the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
whoever builds a Masid for the sake of
Allah subhana tala Allah will build for
him a similar house in Jenna on that day
where Allah subhana tal tells us that
our books will be given and every little
atam weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you and our people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
oh
[Music]